who would like to start us off yep
I can't good this is very sure okay
the the numbers that you're using all
right
you absolutely absolutely must keep them
because otherwise yeah you're in trouble
in fact if you even lose a single page
right all the other pages become
worthless right because we have to start
at exactly the same spot and then
progress right yeah that's right if
you're if a single number gets removed
you're like whoo yes this is a waste
okay so copula I guess you could put
that under the general heading off the
security all the one-time pads right
okay they must be kept secure all right
another one nicotiana okay that's all
right so let's see if we can um
articulate this right and this is what I
was trying to allude to when I held this
up okay five columns right one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen rows 513 65
characters this whole page all I can
send it is a 65 character message that's
exactly right Andy I need everything
right so can I say this I guess there it
is a length limitation right there's a
lengthy rotation because the longer the
message I want to send I physically need
more pages in my one-time pad okay and
if I don't know in our pages I just
can't send them right and it has to be
one-to-one all right the implementation
can't be lost
okay all right question Marcus can you
elaborate a little bit now what that
means
what can you explain about that or can
you maybe give us an example of what you
mean
- one point okay alright someone else
want to do something they can actually
tell us what it means commit good okay
so I guess you could say it's
error-prone right because you have to
read this thing and if something is just
slightly off if I just miss a character
right or if the person reading it back
just misses a character I guess you're
kind of back in this boat right where
your data isn't gonna be exactly the
same okay good man another one
okay so I'll put that I'll put that
together here right time-consuming
because that kind of is the same thing
as its airport you're gonna take a long
time to do it carefully right yep
okay now spaces is kind of a yeah you
could just leave it as a space cruise
leaders face or you could assign it some
other character like I could make that
my 27th letter in the alphabet
aha okay so that's nice to get to my
next one which no one else has guessed
yet which is that we have to agree right
but not only do I have to agree how do I
start off this lesson how did I make
sure that the person who I'm giving his
message to can decipher my message and I
had to walk over here and I had to
physically give the same my duplicate
copy of the one time pad to the person
I'm sending to right now that's no
problem when the person you're sending
to is two meters away from you okay but
I'm just gonna assume usually the whole
point of encryption is you're sending
things to people who are far away so
therefore the problem is the exchange of
the one-time pads in the first place
okay what this assumes is I have to get
it over to his physical location right
and that process is not easy what if I
send it in the mail then someone else
can get it or do I have to walk up to
and catch a plane and hand it to him to
make sure he gets it and gets it intact
okay so that is a problematic
okay so so I'm gonna put together
punctuation spacers it's all this kind
of that that can be sort of
mathematically dealt with if we have
extra letters all those kinds of things
or you could just ignore them
you know like telegrams in the olden
days when they sent messages right
they'll have to send messages like this
they all would say I have I have arrived
and then because they had no punctuation
they would say stop and then they would
just keep going right so that was the
system they use you can get away with it
okay exactly right exactly right okay so
I guess why would you do this I suppose
what this allows you to do is send more
than one message okay so we can exchange
the one time has and then I can leave
and I don't have to come to him again we
can use out the system for the rest of
it but you're right okay all right okay
all right I think that's student
improvement how do you agree what how
the code is encouraging in which case
then someone can then work out what our
curtain is anytime all right let me give
you let me give you the other ones that
I thought of otherwise we run out of
time okay so I want to keep going
they're like punctuation there are ways
to get away not you could just say one
which is fine so yeah okay so let's it
can't be lost it has to be kept
completely secret right but I suppose
that's the same as most kinds of siphons
right the one big weakness that we're
missing and actually is a critically
important one because historically this
is how one-time pads were broken is that
the one-time pads they must be
completely perfectly
now what I mean by random is there's no
way to predict based on you know some of
the numbers what the next number will be
the next time will be the next number
would be now what I did was I'll tell
you how I did this the way I generated
these numbers was I went into Excel and
it has a random number function okay I
said spit me out a random number between
1 and 26 and then I just copied it all
the way across ok now what do you look
at looks pretty random it looks pretty
random but the thing is how does a
computer come up with a random number
how does it do that right where is it
going to go and the answer is it's going
to turn to maths because that's all
computers can do but Matt is not random
maths is predictable even the things
that look unpredictable right like for
example if I wrote up this series of
numbers to you it kind of looks it has
the appearance of randomness but you
know it's not random it's completely
ordered so these are the digits of pi it
looks random but it's not so these
digits right though they look random
depending on how I get them they
actually may be predictable and one-time
pads have been cracked in the past
historically during Wars because people
worked out if you can work out a section
of this you can start to determine
what's the rule how do they generate
these things okay and then you can work
out what happens in the future right so
they must be perfectly random which is a
lot harder than it sounds even you if I
asked you to put together a random list
of numbers okay it's actually very
difficult to do you have to think of
numbers and actually there are
statistical ways just like a better
frequency right to determine if double
you know the series of numbers that
you've given me was generated by a
computer if was generated by hee